PRAKASH: Namaste, Elias.
ELIAS: Oh, hi, there, Prakash.
PRAKASH: [NON-ENGLISH SPEECH]
ELIAS: What?
PRAKASH: I'm sorry.
What I mean is, you seem happy.
How's the day going for you?
ELIAS: I'm doing fine.
But, Prakash, how many
languages do you speak?
PRAKASH: Well, I speak Hindi,
Konkani, my mother tongue,
Kannada, and a couple more.
ELIAS: Woah, that's impressive.
You know, our
customers have users
that speak many
languages, and Google has
tools to help translate texts.
But how do we help customers
with industry-specific jargon
or technical material that
needs to be translated
to a different language?
PRAKASH: You mean like
"server" in a restaurant
should be translated differently
from "server" in a data center?
ELIAS: Exactly.
PRAKASH: Well,
Elias, Google Cloud
has created just
the thing for this.
It's called AutoML Translate.
It is a way for our
customers to bring
their business-specific
translation examples
and easily train a custom
machine-learning model
to understand their domain.
Let me show you how it's done.
ELIAS: Let's do it.
[MUSIC PLAYING]
PRAKASH: This is the AutoML
Translation user interface,
and you're looking at some
of the custom models that
are already trained.
Now let's look at some datasets
that are already in place.
These are used to train
up the custom models.
Let's create a new dataset.
First we'll give it a name.
Then we'll select the source
and target languages--
English and Japanese
in this case.
The translation examples can
be supplied in two formats--
TSV and TMX files.
And you can manually
break this up
into training, testing,
and validation datasets,
or you can let the system
do it automatically.
You can upload the
files from your drive
or drop them on
Google Cloud Storage.
For this demo, I'll
pick a file on my drive.
Clicking on Create Dataset
starts the import process,
and this can take a
little while depending
upon the size of the dataset.
For this demo, I already have
a dataset imported, so let's
click through on it.
And on the first screen, you'll
see some sample sentences
drawn from this dataset.
On the Training tab, there's
additional information
about this dataset.
And you can launch the training
by clicking on Start Training.
You can pick the base
model from Google
and train up your
custom model, or you
can continue training a
previously created custom model
as well.
And under the covers, the
system automatically deploys
the necessary resources
and handles the training.
Now, this can take a few hours,
so I have pre-trained a model
already for use in this demo.
So let's go access that model.
Again, when you go
to the Train tab,
you will see some metrics
for this custom model.
The system automatically
generates a blue score
for the custom model.
And if the blue score is
higher than the base model,
it means that translations
done using this model
will be closer to your
reference dataset.
Now, this dataset has
relatively fewer sentence pairs,
so these numbers
are not typical.
In your case, with
larger datasets,
you will see much
better blue scores.
You can, of course,
continue to train this model
and either create a new version
or continue to train this up
until you get the quality
that you're looking for.
Now, once you have the
quality that you need,
you can go to the Predict area.
And in this case, the
system will show you
samples for invoking the custom
model via REST API or Python
code snippets.
And on this screen,
you can quickly
run some translation examples
and compare the results
from your custom model with
the base model from Google.
[MUSIC PLAYING]
So this is how Google Cloud is
making machine learning easily
accessible to everyone by
addressing the two major
challenges that slow down
machine-learning projects--
one, a need for deep
data science skills,
and two, a need to
manage and deploy
your own compute resources.
ELIAS: This is really
great, Prakash.
Thank you.
If you really like this video,
please go ahead and share,
comment, and subscribe.
And also, if you're working
on any cool projects
and would like to get
in contact with us,
please click on the
link in the description.
Thanks for watching.
[MUSIC PLAYING]